as fears over the coronavirus grow
people are frantically buying up
supplies leaving the store shelves look
at that empty prices are also
skyrocketing online we found two large
bottles of Purell you know that hand
sanitizer on sale for two hundred and
ninety-nine dollars on amazon that makes
make that three hundred dollars that
size normally sells for about nine
dollars a bottle and a right an amazon
spokesperson says the company does not
allow price gouging and it has recently
blocked or removed tens of thousands of
offers our consumer investigative
correspondent Andrew Warner is at a
pharmacy in Manhattan where the products
are selling very fast boy ana you move
very fast cuz ten minutes ago I swear
you were just right there in the green
room so what are you seeing in the
pharmacy I was yes yeah fortunately Gail
I am close by you know millions of
Americans are on the hunt for the same
thing products they think will protect
them against the corona virus now here
at this pharmacy the Shelf where you
would normally see the Purell hand
sanitizer look it's empty and it's a
similar scene at stores around the
country from coast to coast retail
stores are selling out of products like
hand sanitizer disinfectant wipes and
masks a California woman posted this
video from a Costco store where she says
hundreds of people lined up Thursday
morning to buy items that were limited
in New York City pharmacies are having
trouble keeping up with demand this is
where our hand sanitizer comes soon as
we get it it's off the shelf so when an
order comes in within about an hour it's
all gone and we try to keep it to a
limit three to a customer one New Jersey
woman says she went to six stores before
finding hand sanitizer when I learned to
pay she's had fifty dollars and I think
that's disgusting and they're taking
advantage of people right now some say
they won't pay the sky-high prices I
think if you just get soap and washed
your hands for like 20 seconds I think
it'd be fine online sales of virus
protection products have skyrocketed up
eight hundred seventeen percent in the
last two months this Amazon listing
offers four boxes of
asks usually about $20 for over $1000
amazon says it's blocking or removing
thousands of offers where bad actors are
attempting to artificially raise prices
on basic need products during a global
health crisis now states and cities are
cracking down California's Attorney
General told businesses that if they
violated price gouging laws you'd better
be prepared to pay the price for your
law breaking and new york city is
issuing $500 fines to any stores found
price gouging starting this week
commissioner Laurel a solace from New
York City's department of consumer and
worker protection this is not the time
to be trying to make a quick buck on the
backs of hard-working people who are
just very anxious and scared the
businesses are going to have to make
sure that they either are keeping the
prices what what should be a normal
fluctuation or they'll have to justify
the price increase meanwhile health
officials say the best way to protect
yourself is to wash your hands for 20
seconds they say masks are a good idea
for people who are already sick so you
don't pass the virus to somebody else
but they say that masks will not protect
you from getting sick Gail hey Anna are
there long lines if they're at the
drugstore there or is it because there's
nothing there nobody's trying to find
anything over there these days you know
I don't know I'm guessing that a lot of
people are going to several locations
several store locations and going online
to see where they can find items but we
are hearing widespread reports here in
the city that everything is sold out
we've checked with stores like Costco
and Target and numerous pharmacies and
there it seems like there's nothing left
yep that's what happened to me
CVS yesterday we're standing in a long
line complaining about we couldn't get
what we came to get right so I just got
vanilla cookies simple soap and water
yes they'll do the trick they say sing
happy birthday while you're washing your
hands and look cookie that are also a
comfort yes they are with some raisins
are delicious thank you Anna